hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the conclusion to tom's
summary of gilligan's ethics of care and
some of the criticisms that have been
made
in response to those criticisms she says
that
we don't want to try to you know rule
traditional caring roles out all
together
the world like she said it would be a
much worse place tomorrow than there
were today if
women were suddenly to stop meeting the
physical and psychological needs of
those
who depend on them just because men and
yes children have more or less routinely
taken advantage of some women's
willingness to serve them does not mean
that every woman's
caring action should be contemptuously
dismissed as yet another instance of
pathological masochism fear success and
passivity
so she says care is worth rescuing care
is a value
is worth rescuing from these these you
know
ways of domination she calls them
patriarchal structures we can think of
as
historical ways in which women have
gotten the short end of the stick
and sometimes still do get the short end
of the stick
in less in some parts of our culture but
equal in some other parts
so she says a person cannot truly care
for someone
if they're forced to do so and what
would that compulsion be
if they're economically forced to care
for someone so if you're stuck in a
situation where
the only way that you can actually stay
alive or you know put food on the table
is to care for another person
it's a bit coercive it's not something
that you can choose to give
socially if it's just a matter of social
expectations you know very traditional
communities
or psychologically somebody's coercing
that person psychologically
so a person cannot truly care if they're
forced to do so
only under conditions she says of sexual
equality and freedom can women care for
men
in any without any way diminishing
disempowering and or disregarding them
so until these conditions are achieved
that's that's kind of a utopian
view until these are cheap we want to
have some criteria
for what care ought to look like so
she says care has to
fulfill the one
that is caring so it has to be something
that the person who is engaging in the
care
can say yes this this is important to me
this is satisfying to me
this is something that i can willingly
choose and endorse
as part of my good the way i want to be
the kind of person i want to be
that would rule out a lot of cases where
somebody just has to care because
they're the one who's you know is that
their role or it's expected of them
this is really interesting she says
calls upon
the unique
and particular
so if i am caring for
my daughter
there's no substitute for my caring for
my daughter
somebody else could care for her but it
would not be the same
care you know i die
she gets some step dad somewhere down
the line or some father figure or
something like that
that's good it's i would love for her to
be cared for by somebody else
but it won't be my individuality
that'll do that there's certain things
that i've shared with her
for example i used to take her fishing
you know or we would go out
and blaze trails um through through the
woods
we you know certainly like i remember
one time it was kind of silly to bring
it up but
it was you know machete and i was
hacking away and stuff
and i cut my thumb she got real worried
because i started to bleed a lot
you know and i stopped the bleeding and
i
you know don't tell anyone we had a
little secret between us
you know but that's that's how care
takes place and those
those are things are part of our
individuality in particular
particularly what you've shared with
your parents
what you're going to share with people
you care for
when you're carrying that that matters
that's why you can't be substituted for
so that's one important criteria the
third important criteria
is not produced by a person in a role
because of gender with one gender
engaging in nurturing behavior the other
engaging in instrumental behavior
so it's not based
on gender
roles so the guy doesn't get to
automatically assume
i'm going to show up and and get cared
for because
i'm the guy and there's certain ways in
which
women also traditionally expect caring
to take place
that this would also rule out as well
the
i'm not going to work you're just
supposed to take care of me sort of
sort of thing financially that would
rule that out as well
but for the most part she's concerned
about men
coming in and saying you know where's my
dinner
right that's sort of stereotypical
type of type of stuff here's a very
that extends it a bit further
this won't be possible at a certain
sense
genuine care is reciprocated by the
other person
caring in return this will only be
possible in some circumstances though
right if you're caring for somebody
who's an invalid
they probably won't be able to give you
the level of care
that you're giving them obviously caring
for children
is you know dealing with very egoistic
beings for a long long time who are not
that respectful
of your wants and needs or desires or
anything like that so parents eventually
come up and say get that
out of here i just want some time for
myself you know
but in say in adult relationships think
about a friendship for example
if you care about your friend that
friend
want to be caring about you in return
right
otherwise it's kind of a one-way
relationship and you're being taken
advantage you're being taken advantage
of
in your your caring and this does happen
to a lot of people
um then her fifth thing
this might be a bit optional depending
on what you want to make of it
takes place within
the framework
of consciousness
raising
now you know when you talk about that it
sounds like a uh
very academic kind of class thing or
activism doesn't it
like uh engaging consciousness raising
kind of
actually reminds me of the hippies for
my age
i don't know what it reminds you guys of
it but
you hear this sort of stuff all the time
it doesn't have to be like that what do
they mean by consciousness raising
becoming aware of things becoming aware
of what's going on
you know so for example getting into an
adult relationship
let's say it's a romantic relationship
where you and your partner
equally care about each other could help
you to actually understand
how your parents behave towards each
other and whether it was good or bad
that would be an example of
consciousness raising
it helps you understand things better i
think she means that in a very political
sense
you probably don't necessarily need to
to push it that that way
but if you like that sort of thing that
you know
and you know get together i guess once a
week and
talk about how your relationship is
helping you understand politics i don't
think that would be a bad thing but
i think this could be more about our own
past our narratives where we're going
that sort of thing so what do you think
is this enough to sort of guarantee
that care
is going to
be exercised rightly will this keep you
on the tracks
or not do you think there's anything
left out
any criteria that need to be in there
that aren't in there
this is kind of a work in processes
ethics of care stuff
so it's good to think about that